>>> IN OUR POLITICS LEAD TODAY,
CAMPAIGNG FOR PENNSYANIA
GOVERNOR YESTERDAY, REPUBLICAN
NOMINEE DOUG MASTRIANO, A
FULL-THROATED SPREADER OF DONALD
TRUMP'S ELECTION LIES, ATTACKED
HIS RIVAL, DEMOCRATIC ATTORNEY
GENERAL JOSH SHAPIRO, BECAUSE OF
SHAPIRO'S BACKGROUND.
>> HE GREW UP IN A PRIVILEGED
NEIGHBORHOOD, ATTENDED ONE OF
THE MOST PRIVILEGED SCHOOLS IN
THE NATION AS A YOUNG MAN, NOT
COLLEGE.
I'M TALKING ABOUT AS A KID.
SENDING HIS FOUR KIDS TO THE
SAME PRIVILEGED EXCLUSIVE ELITE
SCHOOL.
WE TALK ABOUT HIM HAVING DISDAIN
FOR PEOPLE LIKE US.
>> I HAPPEN TO KNOW A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE PRIVILEGED SCHOOL THAT
MR. MASTRIANO IS ATTACKING
BECAUSE I WENT THERE TOO.
I WAS FOUR-YEAR-OLD AHEAD OF
ATTORNEY GENERAL JOSH SHAPIRO.
IT WAS THEN CALLED AKIBA HEBREW
ACADEMY.
IT'S A PROVIDE JEWISH PAROCHIAL
SCHOOL.
AND I SUPPOSE IN THAT SENSE IT
IS PRIVILEGED.
BUT I DO NOT KNOW MANY PEOPLE
WHO WOULD DESCRIBE IT THE WAY
THAT MR. MASTRIANO DID.
MORE THAN 60% OF THE STUDENT
BODY IS CURRENTLY ON SOME FORM
OF TUITION ASSISTANCE, THE
SCHOOL TELLS ME, WHICH WAS MY
EXPERIENCE BACK WHEN I WENT
THERE IN THE 1980s.
A LOT OF KIDS GOT FINANCIAL AID
INCLUDING A LOT OF KIDS WHO WITH
THEIR PARENTS HAD ESCAPED
ANTI-SEMITISM IN THE SOVIET
UNION AND WERE TRYING TO BUILD
BETTER LIVES FOR THEMSELVES IN
THE PHILADELPHIA AREA.
I DON'T THINK I'VE EVER HEARD
MR. MASTRIANO DESCRIBE ANY OTHER
PENNSYLVANIA PAROCHIAL SCHOOLS
IN THAT WAY.
ELITE, EXCLUSIVE, PRIVILEGED,
FULL OF DISDAIN FOR FELLOW
AMERICANS.
PHILADELPHIA HAS A TON OF FANCY
PREP SCHOOLS.
BUT AKIBA HEBREW ACADEMY WAS NOT
ONE OF THEM.
THE CATHOLIC SCHOOL DOWN THE
STREET SEEMED MORE SIMILAR TO
OUR SCHOOL.
KIDS OF PEOPLE, SOME OF THEM
WEALTHY, SOME OF MIDDLE CLASS,
SOME MORE HUMBLE.
MANY OF THEM FROM FAMILIES WHERE
BOTH PARENTS WORKED.
FROM ALL OVER THE AREA, NEW
JERSEY, DELAWARE, PHILLY,
PENNSYLVANIA, WANTING THEIR KIDS
TO GET AN EDUCATION THAT
INCLUDED FAITH AND ETHICS AND
MORALS.
IS THAT -- IS THAT BAD?
OR IS IT ONLY BAD WHEN THOSE
PAROCHIAL SCHOOLS AREN'T
CHRISTIAN?
WE REACHED OUT AND ASKED TO
SPEAK TO MR. MASTRIANO TODAY ON
OUR SHOW.
WE DID NOT GET A RESPONSE.
I HAVE QUESTIONS FOR HIM,
THOUGH, ABOUT HIS ATTACK ON THIS
JEWISH SCHOOL BECAUSE MR.
MASTRIANO ALSO HAS CLOSE TIES
WITH GAB, THE FAR RIGHT SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORM WHERE NAZI VENOM
IS REGULARLY SPEWED.
GAB, YOU MIGHT RECALL, IS WHERE
THE TREE OF LIFE SYNAGOGUE MASS
MURDERER WAS SHARING HIS PLANS
AND HIS SICK BIGOTRY RIGHT
BEFORE HE CARRIED OUT THE
DEADLIEST ACT OF ANTI-SEMITIC
VIOLENCE IN THE HISTORY OF THE
UNITED STATES.
RIGHT ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
PENNSYLVANIA.
MASTRIANO HAS CLOSE TIES WITH
OPENLY, PROUDLY ANTI-SEMITIC GAB
FOUNDER ANDREW TORBA, WHO WAS
PAID FOR CONSULTING SERVICES BY
THE MASTRIANO CAMPAIGN.
TORBA REGULARLY ATTACKS JEWS.
HE CALLS JOSH SHAPIRO THE
ANTICHRIST.
WE SHOULD NOTE THAT AFTER SOME
JEWISH REPUBLICANS A COUPLE
MONTHS AGO CRITICIZED MASTRIANO
FOR THIS RELATIONSHIP MASTRIANO
ISSUED A RATHER ROTE PAPER
STATEMENT CRITICIZING
ANTI-SEMITISM IN ALL ITS FORMS.
AND THEN YESTERDAY HE ATTACKED
JOSH SHAPIRO'S JEWISH SCHOOL AND
HIS KIDS' JEWISH SCHOOL.
I SHOULD ALSO NOTE THAT CONTRARY
TO WHAT MR. MASTRIANO SUGGESTED
THE JEWISH VALUES TAUGHT THERE
DID NOT TEACH DISDAIN IN MY
EXPERIENCE.
THEY TAUGHT COMMUNITY AND
CHARITY AND RESPECT FOR ALL
FAITHS AND NATIONALITIES, RACES,
CREEDS AND COLORS, LOVE OF THE
UNITED STATES, LOVE FOR OUR
FELLOW AMERICANS.
SO I'M NOT SURE WHAT MR.
MASTRIANO MEANS WHEN HE REFERS
TO PEOPLE LIKE JOSH SHAPIRO
HAVING DISDAIN FOR PEOPLE "LIKE
US."
THE ONLY DISDAIN I EVER FELT
THERE WAS FOR ANTI-SEMITES.
CNN'S JEFF ZELENY JOINS US NOW
LIVE.
JEFF, DOUG MASTRIANO'S
RELATIONSHIP WITH GAB'S FOUNDER
PLAYS INTO LARGER CONCERNS OF
ANTI-SEMITISM IN THIS RACE.
TELL US ABOUT THAT.
>> Reporter: LOOK, JAKE, THE
PENNSYLVANIA GOVERNOR'S RACE IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO THE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS ASSOCIATION AND
REPUBLICANS WRIT LARGE.
THAT IS WHY THEY HAVE BEEN
WORRIED ABOUT DOUG MASTRIANO.
THAT IS WHY MANY OF THE
ESTABLISHMENT REPUBLICAN LEADERS
HERE IN WASHINGTON AND BEYOND
DID NOT SUPPORT HIM IN THE
PRIMARY.
BUT LOOK, HE IS THE NOMINEE.
BUT YES, THERE HAVE BEEN
CONCERNS HANGING OVER THIS RACE,
AS YOU SAID, FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS ABOUT HIS
ASSOCIATION WITH ANTI-SEMITIC
GROUPS.
NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
THE REPUBLICAN JEWISH COALITION,
A VERY PROMINENT ORGANIZATION
HERE IN WASHINGTON WITH DONORS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, WAS VERY
EXPLICIT ABOUT THIS EARLIER THIS
SUMMER, CALLING OUT DOUG
MASTRIANO TO SAY MORE ABOUT HIS
TIES TO ANTI-SEMITISM.
AND DOUG MASTRIANO DID PUT OUT A
STATEMENT AT THAT TIME.
BUT LOOK, THIS IS STILL HANGING
OVER THIS RACE WITHOUT QUESTION.
NOW THERE IS A NEW AD THAT'S
BEEN INTRODUCED IN THIS CAMPAIGN
BY JOSH SHAPIRO.
OF COURSE THE DEMOCRATIC
ATTORNEY GENERAL RUNNING FOR
GOVERNOR.
HE IS POINTING OUT THAT DOUG
MASTRIANO ONCE WAS PICTURED IN A
CONFEDERATE ARMY UNIFORM WHEN HE
WAS AN INSTRUCTOR AT THE ARMY
WAR COLLEGE.
I THINK WE HAVE A PICTURE OF
THAT THAT WE CAN SHOW.
AND HE WAS THE ONLY ONE ON THE
FACULTY HERE THAT DECIDED TO USE
THE CONFEDERATE UNIFORM HERE IN
HIS PICTURE.
SO THAT HAS BEEN NOW TURNED INTO
A DIGITAL AD.
SO YES, THIS IS ALL HANGING OVER
THE RACE HERE.
AND IT'S A RACE THAT AT THIS
POINT JOSH SHAPIRO IS LEADING.
A NEW CBS NEWS POLL SHOWS THAT
HE IS LEADING MASTRIANO BY 55 TO
44% THERE.
EIGHT WEEKS BEFORE THE ELECTION
THIS IS THE STATE OF THE
GUBERNATORIAL CAMPAIGN AT LEAST
IN PENNSYLVANIA, JAKE.
>> YEAH.
IN ADDITION TO BEING LOSERS AND
TRAITORS WE SHOULD NOTE THAT THE
CONFEDERATES -- PENNSYLVANIA WAS
NOT ON THE SIDE OF THE
CONFEDERATES.
WE WERE ON THE WINNING SIDE.
DEMOCRAT JOHN FETTERMAN, THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR, HE'S
FINALLY AGREED TO A DEBATE
FOLLOWING A WAVE OF CRITICISM
AND OF COURSE HIS STROKE.
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT THAT?
>> HE HAS AGREED TO A DEBATE
THAT'S SCHEDULED NOW TENTATIVELY
FOR OCTOBER 25th, TWO WEEKS
BEFORE THE ELECTION, AND HE'S
ASKED FOR CLOSED CAPTIONING TO
BE USED AT THE DEBATE.
WHY?
HE STILL IS HAVING AUDITORY
ISSUES, HIS CAMPAIGN SAYS,
HAVING A HARD TIME HEARING AND
PROCESSING SOME THINGS BECAUSE
OF THAT STROKE HE HAD SEVERAL
MONTHS AGO.
SO THE OZ CAMPAIGN, MEHMET OZ
CAMPAIGN, HAS AGREED TO THE
CLOSED CAPTIONING AS LONG AS THE
MODERATOR ANNOUNCES AND EXPLAINS
IT TO THE AUDIENCE IN ADVANCE.
WE'LL SEE IF THIS DEBATE
ACTUALLY HAPPENS.
AS IN MANY STATES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, THERE'S BEEN A DEBATE
OVER DEBATES.
BUT HERE IN PENNSYLVANIA IT'S
BEEN DIFFERENT BECAUSE IT'S
SPEAKING TO FETTERMAN'S HEALTH
ISSUES.
BUT AS OF